[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing
relationships open phones Jade wash all
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five we are
breaking all records in Ramsey
publishing this week with the launch of
the pre-sale of Dr John deloney's new
book building a non-anxious life
apparently there's a need
yeah man people I'm joining you guys too
today just for a segment here talk about
the book but yeah it's evidently we are
an anxious stressed burned out culture
man we knew this yeah statistically the
stats were telling us the the statistics
of Despair they're called are really in
bad shape yeah and have been declining
since well before covet and covet kind
of put on the accelerator and
highlighted it was there's problems out
there yeah and it it's uh they're
actually called the diseases of Despair
when you kind of back out and look at
the resources we have in our culture and
the wealth we have in our culture and
the just the technology and Brilliance
there's really no reason why
people are dying younger and why people
are more lonely than ever and why
marriages are falling apart and why the
suicide rate is up so dig into this why
depression is up why everybody is just
rattled with anxiety and so yeah this
book was just a hey what we're doing is
not working let's let's look at this a
different way we did a chapter book with
John a couple years ago we call them
quick reads the 37 Pages called
redefining anxiety it blew up 150 000
copies out of the gate with no promotion
and the whole idea of that book is woven
into uh building a non-anxious life
because part of building an unanxious
life really almost the first thing you
have to do is you have to grasp what
anxiety is and what it isn't that's
exactly right and the narrative we've
been given is it's it's a genetic
disorder like we talked about yesterday
it's something wrong with you you're
broken and we got to fix what's broken
and really what anxiety is is just an
alarm system man letting you know that
you are not all right okay and so really
you gotta back out of that thing and say
okay not let's just pull the batteries
out of the alarm but where's my house on
fire where's the fire let's put that
fire out well and like you quoted one
author that said anxiety is actually
good because it's telling you
something's wrong Yeah Wendy Suzuki says
Dr Suzuki says anxiety is a friend he's
trying to get your attention and let you
know things aren't okay yeah and uh it
it it especially applies to this this
conversation we have on this show on the
Ramsey Show
if you owe money
you've been saying this for 30 years
Financial Peace if you owe somebody
money
your your frontal lobe the part of your
brain is designed for for a complex
thinking and for projecting into the
future it can convince you that that
zero percent financing for seven years
on that depreciating asset you got a
good deal and mathematically maybe you
actually did get a good deal the part of
your brain that's designed to keep you
alive knows if you say one wrong thing
at work you're fired you lose your car
you lose your house you lose your food
and so when you owe money your body will
not let you have rest and that we call
that anxiety we call that burnout we
call that chronic stress but that's just
one example of the way our culture has
just said here's the new way to do life
forgetting that as vessel of intercourt
says the body keeps the score the body
will let you know that what we're doing
is not right what I love about this book
is you've
uh broken it down into things that we
can do each day right this is a
lifestyle from here on out after we read
this book right yeah and it's it's uh
frustrating the problems not the
symptoms that's right and it's
frustrating
um there's my buddy Elaine Norton says
there's never a workout you can do on a
Monday that's so great that you don't
have to work out for the rest of the
week or the rest of the month right
second shape being healthy it's just a
thing you got to do every day there's
never one meal like one salad you can
eat that's so great that just buys you
Dunkin Donuts for the rest of the month
right and so um similarly with anxiety I
know Dave's like no no yes if you find
it tell me about it
um so when it comes to living a
non-anxious life it's it's a way you got
to live you got to choose reality you
got to choose Freedom you got to choose
friendship and connection you gotta
choose to heal
um you got to choose to believe in
something bigger than yourself and so
there's there's just these choices you
can make on a daily basis a monthly
basis in a yearly basis that are going
to transform your life if you want to
discover the six daily choices that will
help you move towards one of them is
getting your financial act together okay
they help you move towards having a
non-anxious life removing the things
that are causing anxiety in other words
filling up your tank things like quality
relationships getting your finances in
control it's kind of Common Sense stuff
biblical stuff uh it's really not rocket
science it's written in a way that you
can reach the Shelf this book is on I
promise you okay so it's right there
where the cookies are you can get it so
hey check it out uh it's a 20 book if
you buy it in pre-sale it actually comes
out October 3rd it went on pre-sale this
week if you buy it in pre-sale we're
going to bribe you to buy it early and
give you 75 dollars worth of extra
goodies including the audiobook and the
e-book and they'll come out with the
book but in the meantime instant access
to Dr John deloney's newest talk smoke
fire and freedom that breaks down some
of the mythology and so be sure and
check this out it's all
mzsolutions.com
ramseysolutions.com the new book is
building a non-anxious Life by Dr John
deloney uh his last one on your past
change your future was the number one
best seller again the little the little
quick read was a massive blow up uh so
this one will be as well without a doubt
just because we're helping people with
an area that they really need help with
it's not it's not something we dreamed
up it's something we recognized yeah and
I I want to call out something you said
a minute ago
um I spent my last 20 years of my life
reading academic journals talking with
um scientists and Brilliant Minds
this book isn't for them this book is
for people who don't read books and who
want a better life this is a book for
people who are tired of being talked
down at told that they're stupid told
that they're dumb that they have a
disease that they're broken yeah there's
some kind of malfunction this book is
for somebody who
um wants a clear simple way to change
their life right change change the the
the culture and the warmth inside their
home right yeah and I said this
yesterday and I want to say it again
this book's for everyone that's right
whether you think that you've you might
be sitting there gone you know I've got
my mental health in order I'm doing
pretty good I was a person who thought
man I'm not really anxious I I'm good I
read your book all of them redefining
anxiety own your password this one and
I'm like I'm well I'm starting on this
one and I'm like everybody needs this
well it will help everyone everyone that
doesn't need a little more peace raise
your hand and uh those of you that you
know that raise your hand uh how long
have you had a problem with lying I mean
sure right the joke is either you're
struggling with this or you're married
to somebody who is okay so it's in your
house it's somewhere you just walk past
someone I promise you so yeah and here's
the thing if you have a broken part of
your life that's causing anxiety taking
a pill won't make it go away right and
the people that think taking a pill
makes everything go away are not gonna
like this book well in Medicaid I talk
about my journey with medication what
medication does is it turns the alarms
down and allows you to go do the work
that you need to do but dedication not
all medication is bad we're not saying
that but it doesn't um it doesn't make
you not anxious forever it doesn't solve
the problem right it allows you to get
under the hood get in there and do the
work that you need to do that's right
the spark plugs are not well the fuel
injectors they are not cool yeah if
you're not interested in doing the work
kind of like getting out of debt if
you're waiting for Washington to come
save you it's not the book for you if
you are ready to take control of your
life back this is this is the book for
you building a non-anxious life Dr
chandeloni at ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
thank you
foreign
buying Market but there's a way you can
get an edge Churchill Mortgage works
with you to understand your budget and
your goals and the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge offers you fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus Churchill has bumped up their
seller guarantee to ten thousand dollars
giving your offer the best chance of
being accepted and helping you win in
today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Peter is with us in Canada
hi Peter welcome to the Ramsey Show
um so I'm currently entering my third
year of University
I'm married me and my wife have been
very financially independent
we're both in school we're both foresee
being able to pay off for our school uh
just through hard-earned cash while just
doing summer jobs wonderful
um
we've been doing them we've been kind of
realizing you know that the student loan
rate in Canada we don't have interest on
our student loans and we don't start
paying until
six months after graduate and so we were
wondering are we thinking about
maximizing out the student loans we can
take outs and putting it aside in a
separate High interest savings account
uh maybe even in invest into some
short-term bonds and then when we
graduate uh take all that money out uh
pay off our student loans in full and
then you know keep the keep the money
that we made from from the interest my
question is uh what what I know that
you're very adamant about
staying out of debt if possible no I'm
just very good not not if possible I'm
just adamant about staying out of debt
period
right but let's go ahead how much are
you talking about doing how much money
uh me so about fifteen thousand dollars
uh a year for me and my wife so that's
about thirty thousand dollars each yeah
so sixty thousand dollars
yeah okay and and the uh bond rate is
what
it's about five and a half percent okay
okay all right so three thousand bucks
um that's what you're gonna make per
year that's what you're gonna make three
thousand dollars and what's your degree
in
Finance
yeah okay
um
and you're in your third year of Finance
degree
no so I'm just doing Bachelor of
Commerce currently uh majoring majoring
in finance yeah going and going into
method
um have have you ever had a statistics
class yet
not yet not yet okay I can tell okay
um go ahead Dave
um
so here's what you're missing
risk
the only way your program works is if
there is a zero risk scenario which does
not exist
okay
so the problem is you call the guy
that's been doing this for 35 years so
I've seen everybody do every possible
stupid butt thing they can do in their
lives or have horrible tragedies happen
to them in their lives that you have not
anticipated or
oh maybe the bond market has a problem
that's never happened has it of course
that happens all the time
and so maybe you don't make three
thousand
and uh maybe oh have you did you know
that bonds go down in value when
interest rates go up you know it's an
inverse relationship
yeah yeah
and so you're going to take out a sixty
thousand dollar loan with sixty thousand
dollars worth of bonds interest rates go
up now your bonds are worth fifty
thousand dollars but you have to repay
sixty thousand dollars
you know values go down when interest
rates go up it's an inverse relationship
with them on the market to interest rate
somewhere in the rising interest rate
environment aren't we
is that that's called a risk okay so
your plan is
um
not good it's left out
key components which makes it really
really risky and naive that's problem
number one with it problem number two
with it is you are trying to make money
doing nothing
making money doing nothing usually will
cause you problems
so don't try to make money doing nothing
problem number three is I'm pretty sure
I'm not positive but I
am just about positive that the
government of Canada did not come up
with a student loan program for Peter to
invest in the bond market
meaning that you are misusing these
funds which is not illegal but it is at
a minimum unethical or immoral I agree
with that
so
um
lots of reasons Peter to not do this
lots of reasons you do not anticipate
risk
another way that you can if you're ever
faced with something like this again
that help you feel the risk is just take
your proposed scenario and multiply it
like 10 or 100x
and see if it doesn't make you want to
throw up a little bit that's so good
then you really see the gravity of it so
in other words what you do this with six
hundred thousand dollars if you could do
it would you do this with six million
dollars if you could do it oh no so now
you're starting to feel like oh God
something could go wrong well if
something could go wrong well dude
something could go wrong and let me just
tell you it's not something good it's
pretty likely to absolutely it's pretty
likely to so um yeah it's just um an all
for three grand that's my thing it's not
even a lot of money go deliver some
pizzas and get you some three grand for
a year yeah I mean that's just not a lot
yeah you are playing with a barrel full
of snakes for three grand
hoping to not get bit so
um there's the problems with your theory
and because your theory is empty it's
missing entire sets of variables that
when implemented make this really
unattractive and you forgot the ethics
and the morals part of it too which will
also Lead You astray and get you into
problems so Dave that was good I was
expecting you to really go into one of
your Dave modes well
you taught you taught the thing is I um
I it wouldn't have been fair to him
that's true yeah no you caught so he had
to uh because he doesn't know and he
didn't call up with an arrogance he was
asking an honest question and he just
didn't know so it wouldn't have been
fair to him to kill him
um as tempting as it might have been I
was I was I was giving you the energy
yeah I know you were you were I I felt
it I felt you egging me on it's almost
as bad as when Sharon does that but yeah
oh my gosh no I mean he's a he's a good
guy he just hadn't thought about some of
the stuff because he's young and I'm
glad he called in because I know a lot
of people have fooled around with that
idea in different types of way basically
taking debt to invest it so yeah so for
those of you over in the nerd side her
head are still spinning the reason I ask
about statistics class was not to be
sarcastic but
um in Stat one the first class you take
they will teach you uh a measure of risk
called a beta and a beta is the the
distance between the hill and the valley
if you look at a graph and it's going up
and down like a mountain in the valley
the distance between the bottom and the
top is your beta okay so and and so in
an investment analysis a beta is your
measure of risk
and so for those of you out there doing
your Investments you'll see it actually
it's one of the people is you actually
do see it in the real world other than
stat class is with mutual funds so a A
in the in the United States the standard
and poor the S P 500 is the measure the
Baseline of the stock market it is a 1.0
beta so it's your Baseline okay okay so
if you have a mutual fund that has a 0.8
less than one that means it's less
volatile than the stock market if you
have a mutual fund for instance an
aggressive growth stock mutual fund
might have a 2.0 beta which means it's
twice as volatile as the s p Baseline
okay the standard poor Baseline so you
see it there but what happens is people
do not apply that type of mathematical
thinking and formula which that's an
actual math measure of risk no people
don't apply that to debt and see he left
he left risk out of his math formula
yeah he did so he's thinking okay I'm
going to make 3000 sixty thousand but I
did not adjust my returns for risk and
that's why I was asking about that
because you adjust it for risk and this
is really a a an egghead explanation of
why God says in the Bible that the
borrower is slave
to the lender slaves don't have choices
slaves are seldom generous
so slaves lose their personhood and this
is what happens when you step into the
Noose of debt because you haven't
measured risk adequately very good so
this is the you know you look at it
through a Biblical lens a spiritual lens
the lens of faith we can look at it
through the academic lens we can look at
it through Grandma's Common Sense
grandpa says Sean you bought that car
it didn't work that was my grandpa drove
up in a new Jaguar I was a millionaire
my grandpa looked at me like I'd lost my
mind he goes 10 years what's that car
going to be worth and I said not as much
and he said well I call my investments
things that go up
look at that Grandpa was right this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you Jade Warsaw Ramsey personality
is my co-host today in the lobby of
Ramsey Solutions on the debt free stage
Carrie and Liz are with us hey guys how
are you how you doing Dave welcome
welcome good to have you where do you
live
Kansas City all right fun welcome to
Nashville and how much debt have you
guys paid off
424 thousand eight hundred dollars love
it very good and how long did this take
three and a half years all right and
your range of income during that time
anywhere from 2 30 combined to 350. yeah
you got to be filming what do you all do
for a living
I'm a neonatal nurse practitioner oh
there's that okay and I'm a project
director for a general contractor okay I
was gonna guess house but now I'm going
to guess student loans yes
amazing
nurse practitioner wow what a cool job I
mean wow what a neat thing you do every
day and how expensive to get that degree
right
yes all of the above yeah all of the
above wow that was the uh the house as
well oh how did it went down it was the
house oh okay cool congratulations I'm
looking at weird people all right what's
the house worth about 530 way to go and
how much are the four 25 was a house uh
340. so it really wasn't that much
student loans okay 85 was the student
loans okay not not doctor level student
loans anyway huh okay good it's good for
you that's pretty close I mean 85 not
not 385 okay good good way to go guys
congratulations man that's gonna feel
great the student loans the house
everything gone yep all all gone that's
great
my thing is like you've got these great
incomes but you clearly did not let
yourself have that lifestyle in order to
pay this debt off yeah that was a goal
for of ours for sure what what was what
started all of this three and a half
years ago so about three and a half four
years ago uh my Aunt Kim she went
through the the journey as well and she
gave us a free sample of The Total Money
Makeover so we listened to that
um and went home and that night I
couldn't sleep so I ended up paying off
like two thousand dollars in credit
cards
um like three grand and uh my car at the
time and then we just kept that momentum
going wow wait a minute when Liz woke up
you've been up at the computer doing
this that's what I'm thinking so
actually a little bit of our history
here
um why don't you go ahead okay
um
so I was in the middle of school I
graduated in 2019.
um but prior to Carrie and I went to
college together with my late husband so
they were actually like best friends
um so when Matt passed away in in 2018
um I was lucky enough to have a term
life insurance policy through my
employer for 200 000 so then when I
graduated in 2019 I actually put that
money paid off my 85 000
um in student loans using that money and
then invested
um the rest of that so my daughter
Sylvie is here today and she's
um Matt and I's daughter and Carrie is
going to be adopting her here within the
next month so wow that's wonderful yeah
it's a really cool story it was a great
story um we have a lot of a lot of
history together but
um definitely always been on the same
page as far as what we wanted our Legacy
to be for our family so yeah
your uh
I mean with that tragedy you obviously
had a complete reset emotionally and you
don't have a choice but to uh make
serious things serious yeah after that
and so we're gonna clean this mess up
this is serious it's not this is not a
couple of children trying to figure out
what I'm gonna do with the candy yeah
this is all of a sudden real serious and
so so what happened to Matt
he was unfort it was a tragic death but
um
it's a professional for many years and
unfortunately
um became addicted to opioids
and so it was a long road
um and you know for a long time we
couldn't talk about it it was kind of
like the elephant in the room but I'm at
a point in my life now where
um
it's it's a part of my story it's a part
of our story it's a part of Sylvie's
story it's been over overcoming the
whole process definitely and so um you
know he was a wonderful wonderful person
and I like to remember him for
absolutely for all of the good things
and um you know it is he left me with
her and wonderful memories and so for
that we're very grateful amen wow amen
incredible so then the two of you get
married three and a half years we've
been tearing into this debt way to go a
couple of Heroes coming the other side
of that tragedy and gonna we're gonna
make something beautiful out of this
whole thing way to go good work uh what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is and definitely having a
plan uh we're both very fortunate
growing up to have our parents kind of
instill savings and being intentional
um but really again we started listening
to the show three and a half years ago
it kind of gave us a plan to and it gave
us the ability to start setting goals
and realizing what what we need to
accomplish there and just since we've
been married you know even prior to that
just being on the same team
um life throws a lot of challenges at
you but if you can stick together you
can you can get through it also amen
that's a word so you've got no debt in
the world not a house
thing yeah
yeah what's next on the horizon
so we got married last October
um and we held off on the honeymoon a
little bit we just got back from South
Africa wow so we've done that for a week
and then we did the Seychelles nice nice
that was kind of the honeymoon slash uh
debt-free that is great expensive so we
cash flowed our not very cheap honeymoon
so that was part of our plan and and we
achieved it we saved up money as we went
along and you know we paid our money our
wedding off
um before it even happened so that was
also you know not in our debt at all
um big that was a big goal of ours as
well so everything that we say we're
gonna do together we do so just making
sure you're on the same team yeah I'm
making 350 now not a debt in the world
not a house or anything way to go
congratulations you are amazing wow and
what over what the stuff you've come
through and overcome and it's just a
process man it's very beautiful very
well done absolutely very cool
all right let's bring Sophie up how old
is Sylvie she's six did I say her name
correctly you did yes all right she's so
cute she is beautiful yeah
oh what a blessed kid this is awesome
yeah are you ready her life is
absolutely changed hey we've got the uh
live and give box for you which includes
the baby steps Millionaire's book if
you're not there you will be shortly
with these numbers and The Total Money
Makeover book for you to give and get
somebody started like you said somebody
loans you The Total Money Makeover and
the financial piece university
membership again use it or give it away
congratulations you guys you're amazing
thank you what a beautiful thing you've
done I'm so proud of you Heroes well
done well done all right Carrie and Liz
and Sylvie Kansas City 425
000 paid off in three and a half years
making 230 to 350. count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
[Music]
wow wow
wow just in case uh you are facing the
most unbelievable tragedy of your life
today you can look at them and say four
years five years the other side of it
look at what is here I mean my goodness
gracious so um you know the The Sun Will
Come Out Tomorrow that's right several
takeaways from that story several very
good hope yes yeah in so many ways
because I mean when you get you go
through something like that it it's
it's it's hard to believe it's ever
going to get better that's right when
you're in the middle of it and boy what
a beautiful gorgeous outcome yeah
beautiful just fabulous and just I mean
a power couple the future is so bright
for them they've got so much going
there's so many things they can do there
and all because they said okay we're
going to
be very intentional we're gonna have a
plan we're going to be on the same page
we're going to work a plan and they
didn't give any different answers than a
lot of debt free screamers give but boy
they did some big numbers well and you
can tell they have an immense confidence
in each other and the when the ability
of when they both say we're going to do
this like she said they do it yeah you
can see it in the body language you can
yeah that's very cool Power powerful
rock stars heroes well done this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host to the Ramsey Show question of
the day is brought to you by neighborly
your hub for Home Services neighborly is
the place to find Reliable help for your
home from trusted locally owned
businesses like Mr Appliance Mr Handyman
and Precision garage door service visit
neighborly.com today to find home
experts available to serve you today's
question comes from Peter in Alabama I
have a question about one of my best
friends I love him and his family to
death but his financial management is
beyond horrible and it hurts me to watch
someone I care about so much make
idiotic mistakes and dig himself into a
hole that only gets deeper as time goes
on he is not one to ever talk about
money but I know for a fact that he is
dealing with a big student loan and
credit card debt I would love to help
him and turn him over to your show and
the baby steps but I also fear he won't
respond positively to unsolicited
Financial advice my question to you is
how would you approach this this kind of
situation
you know
these situations there some of it
depends on the relationship obviously
like I've got there's certain buddies of
mine that I'd be like look I'm older
than you I know what I'm talking about
then there's situations where I I
probably wouldn't say a whole lot I'd
probably just lead by example and hey
this is what I'm doing and hopefully
they catch on and then there's those
times where you do bring up the
conversation but it's not in like uh
here's what you need to do dude you've
been messing up man like you don't know
what you're doing trust me listen to
Dave like that's not the way to do it
what you can do is say you know I
remember when I had a time that I I
remember when I had credit card debt
remember when I had that thirty thousand
dollars there it is it was crazy and
what I did I found this guy he's on
YouTube he has this book I started
reading the book and I was blown away
exactly don't talk about him at all yeah
just talk about you
and talk about back when you were stupid
because we all we all can go back there
some of us it was 20 minutes ago some of
us it was 20 years ago but we all can go
back to stupid and go I remember when I
had a big student loan how scared I was
I remember how I felt like I would never
get out of it I remember those feelings
man I tell you what and and man I used
to fight people I would argue with
people about credit card points I
thought you're gonna get rich using
credit card points how dumb I was I
can't believe how stupid I was and you
know what I found some new information
and you know what I did I worked my butt
off and I worked this plan that this guy
on the radio these these people on the
radio at Ramsay they talk about and I
got out of debt and man oh you wouldn't
believe I could sleep better right I
might I feel like I got a 300 pound man
off the chair off of my chest you know I
was standing on there I mean and I feel
so much better and just talk about you
and he'll he may just look at you like
you have one eye he might or he might
look at you and say wow
that's pretty cool who who'd you say
that podcast was yeah that may be what
he does because he's pretty he's
probably not going to say hey man help
me do my budget no he's probably not
going to go completely over to the side
but you just tell him about you you got
to talk about it like you would if you
if a restaurant you loved or
Netflix show that you loved you wouldn't
go
and go wrong and all the shows you like
suck watch mine you wouldn't do that you
just say I'm looking at the show I love
it yeah it's great it's so good it's so
entertaining that like you gotta talk
about it like that that way you're never
pointing that finger in their face and
you're not telling them anything bad
about themselves exactly just just share
your experience because really no one
can argue with your experience that's
right I mean this is what happened to me
I don't know what I mean this is what
happened to me and you really and my old
Pastor used to say used to say a man
with an experience is not at the mercy
of a man with an opinion facts
it's not like I'm
I'm it's just like come on man you know
yeah I used to eat 63 donuts and I quit
and I feel so much better now that I'm
not so stinking fat you know look I got
more energy you know I do that's true
you know and so I got more energy you
know my wife likes me better life is
good so you know I'm just recommending
I'm just saying my life is good and man
you know so if you come to me and say
Jade I used to eat 65 Donuts every day I
feel great what is it I used to give me
a hint no no not you at all I wasn't
saying that to you I'm just saying I'm
just saying that to America
America
Josh Josh get us out of this Josh is in
Bristol hey Josh how are you
I'm good how are you today better than
we deserve sir how can we help
yeah
um before I start I just want to say God
bless you all guys and thank you so much
I've been watching a lot of your videos
here recently and I'm working on the
baby steps well thank you sir we're
honored to have you in the audience how
can we help today
um right me and my wife are halfway
um done with baby step one and I had a
car problem I got my car paid off a year
ago but it's it blew up and
I need at least vehicle that I'll have
the
cash change and just buy one and I'm I'm
gonna try well
and I'm becoming very anti-death too but
the only way I know how to do that is
get a small car loans under 10 000
preferably seven
do you do you don't have any money
uh nothing saved up okay what's the car
the car you were driving what was it
worth before it blew up
uh I don't know the kellen's blue book
it was a 2007 Toyota Camry
okay so what would you think it was
worth what would you guess
I think I could probably sells around
three thousand before it blew up yes sir
okay all right so there's no need to get
a seven thousand dollar car then you
were driving a three before this
happened
right okay so we could buy a three
thousand dollar car and break even let's
start with that what's your household
income
um
our time we uh a month we bring in the
four thousand four hundred and eleven
dollars okay good and how much is your
rent
uh we don't have renter mortgage my wife
inherited their house by our grandfather
who passed away a few years ago that's
good news okay and uh both of you work
outside the home
yes sir okay and and you currently have
one car that's running right
yeah it is it's all alone it's my wife's
truck it's
uh we pay for 75 a month for it okay so
it's got a loan on it but you own you
own one other car a 500 car payment on a
four thousand dollar take-home pay ouch
that's no fun
um
and uh you don't uh you don't own
another car right you don't own a third
car do you
know sir okay what's your tractor worth
I don't know what's right what's your
lawnmower worth
there's gonna be real embarrassing I
don't have a loan okay it's not
embarrassing what would be embarrassing
is if you told me you had a seven
thousand dollar zero turn that would be
embarrassing okay because I'd be selling
it to buy you a car okay so you're doing
good Josh you're passing the test so far
you got a lot of common sense I'm just
looking around here because sometimes
sometimes I just got married five months
ago okay good very good so you married
this car payment okay
okay
um what do you do for a living
I'm a housekeeper at a university okay
yeah my wife my wife's a welder in a
factory excellent excellent okay all
right so your car with the blown engine
will probably bring 1500 at the salvage
yard maybe more
I hope so that would be a lot more than
I was thinking yeah a thousand to
fifteen hundred it'll bring uh or some
old boy I'll give you that because he's
going to put an engine in it okay
um yeah I don't want you to put an
engine in it you don't you don't fix
three thousand dollar cars those are
throwaway cars okay all right um
so I'll tell you the you can go the
route you wanted to go but I wouldn't
recommend it and you're brand new to our
stuff so our stuff can sometimes feel
awfully extreme but one of the things I
found is if I'm going to break a series
of bad habits or principles in my life I
have to adopt the extreme to complete
the transformation in my heart okay so
when we went broke Josh I drove a
borrowed car for four months I'm not
suggesting you have a car you can borrow
but I'm just telling you how what I did
okay what I did was I drove a 1978
Cadillac with 478 000 actual miles on it
the predominant color was Bondo and the
vinyl roof was torn loose across the
front so when you drove it it filled up
with air and looked like a parachute on
a Bondo buggy it was the most
embarrassing hillbilly car you can think
of
and I drove that car for three months
one ten year period
it's what it felt like 10 years it felt
like 10 years it was only three months
but buddy I saved some money during that
three months because I'm getting rid of
Bondo buggy right highly motivated
that's what I was so I'm gonna suggest
you do something weird like that like
let's sell this car for 1500 and go buy
a 1500 car that runs and drive it for
four months and during that four months
oh you can buy it it's a garage sale car
it's ugly it's got a hail dents in it
but it runs oh you want something that
runs you get in a garage sale that's
where you get it you got to air the
tires up
and that and you drive that car for four
months it's Jade look if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsay personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money open phones
about triple eight eight two five five
two two five New Orleans is calling
Britney is with us hi Brittany how are
you
Louie how are you Dave thank you guys so
much for taking my call our pleasure how
can we help
all right so I'm on baby step two
currently but I'm looking to move closer
to my job I currently have about an hour
and 30 to 2 hour round trip daily that I
take good looking closer with him yeah
we'll put me at about a 30 minute
commute daily but the kicker is
currently I'm only paying 800 for rent
but I do spend about 600 on gas every
month moving I would go up 700 in rent
but I would probably cut my expense on
gas to 300 I currently make about 10 to
12K a month but I have about 50 000 left
in debt to pay so I'm trying to decide
on what do you do
I am a school social worker but I do
have two other jobs that I'm working
right now to really kind of get out of
business up to a little quicker so if I
did that math right real quick it's a
450 swing that you're
you would lose by going 30 minutes
closer or by getting it down by getting
it down to 30 minutes yeah
yes
out of and you're making 10 to 12 000 a
month
yes doing what
it's not social work what are you doing
so I do social work I also am working at
FedEx FedEx currently okay um part time
in the mornings I do counseling
um in the afternoons as well and I do
have disability that I get from the
military so all in total about 10 or 12K
okay thank you for your service which
one of those is the big number
um I would say the big number is my
disability all right okay good how much
is that
about 3 900 a month okay so you're
getting like three or four checks for
three grand four grand okay good yeah
all right
uh
yes I'm moving closer yeah
probably not where you think you're
moving
yeah
uh I you know here so I I think there's
a third option uh C which has moved
closer for rent that's about the same I
don't think you want to go over there
or out that far in the country or
whatever that is and I don't want you to
be in a situation that's unsafe I'm not
suggesting that but
um so where when where are you commuting
what's the big commute the counseling or
no the the it would be the social the
social work right yes so
Telehealth okay anywhere good good call
okay thanks for the clarification that's
good so anyway what I'm what I'm going
to suggest is you keep looking mm-hmm
because I think you're I think you have
a valid
point but I also think you can do it
cheaper than what you found
in the area you need to be in your rent
would go from 800 to 1500 a month
yeah so what area are you in now
currently saying
[Music]
you're working what yeah in Destrehan oh
yeah okay all right
um how much debt do you have you said
you're in baby step two how much do you
have yes
50k okay I missed that okay
so all I'm uh yes you need to do
something okay I wouldn't commute an
hour and a half in in the New Orleans
Market that's not a normal commute in
that market it might be in LA but it's
not in New Orleans okay so um I commute
12 minutes so I'm not going to do this
okay period I'm gonna suggest you do
something that direction but I'm also
going to suggest that you shop more and
find something closer to a thousand
which makes this make a lot more sense
so what I'm challenging actually more
than the idea of moving is uh the idea
that you have to move to that particular
place that particular thing so I I want
you to go find a rich old lady in
Bethlehem that has a uh has a
a garage out back with an apartment over
it that a friend at the church tells you
about that's never been on the market
for rent and you go out there and you
rent from her for 800. I want you to
find the weird thing like that instead
of just walking up to the shiny
apartment complex that has a management
team out of Atlanta yeah you know and I
want you to go get I want you to go get
the weird thing that that is perfectly
safe and perfectly clean no roaches no
mold I'm not suggesting this stuff okay
but but what you can find is I mean you
can go to the richest end of town and
find a garage apartment if you know
where to look and know who to talk to
and someone believes you're a good
person to have in the corner and
um I don't know maybe you offer to do
something for the rich old lady to take
care of her in the process or you talk
to her relatives and they put you in
there in your house sit I don't care but
let's get a little more creative and get
this rent down yeah I'd be
a month like she's killing it you're
killing it I'm trying it works all the
time yeah and you're not going to do
that probably forever but it's just you
right you can live on yeah hardly any
anything yeah it doesn't take much space
for you because you're over there in a
normal life the 1500 wouldn't be that
bad it's just well I'm more I don't even
mind the 1500 in this case yeah but what
I'm trying to challenge is this idea
that uh
the we always propose these two things
and neither one of them are good high
rent and it's close right or low rent
and it's far how about low rent and it's
closed let's look for that one that's
all I'm saying we immediately we
immediately think if I lose my job that
I'm going to get a job that pays less
why not lose my job take the severance
pay and get a job that pays more and
keep the severance paying call it a
signing bonus why not think about how a
glass half full there's always a
different way and that's the critical
thinking I'm always trying to push on
that's what I'm doing here that's a good
word so you're you're awesome I like you
I think you're going to do great I'm
proud of you Brittany you're attacking
this you work like a maniac and you're
going to clean up your debt it's going
to be done in no time at the way you're
going but just rent find something that
that you can write about when you write
your story someday that I found this
cool situation like I was telling that
guy a while ago about that car you know
I mean that kind of stuff yeah so yeah
you got to have something like that in
in the mix
um and here's the thing the thing
when you buy a car
when you commute when you uh rent mm-hmm
very seldom for long that's true that is
very true we act like we're doing this
for 20 years now in her case it's going
to be you know it's just a hand it's
just a spit yeah it's just spit it's not
it's not very long and so in the scope
of your life a year two years 18 months
whatever it is you can do anything for
three months yeah I mean you know so
true and she's got more than three
months to go but I mean the the we act
like these decisions are so permanent
but yeah there's no way I'm commuting an
hour and a half I'm moving oh that's
terrible that's torture two hours no
thank you even if you listen to Ramsey
show the entire time
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones are triple
eight eight two five five two two five
everybody's talking about student loans
yes they are and since the government
isn't going to forgive them
which we knew no one is shocked that
that thinks clearly it's not a spoiler
alert no no wasn't gonna happen been
saying it wasn't gonna happen
everybody's mad at me because I said it
wouldn't happen and then I'm right
they're mad at me because I was right so
there you go so get over it you're gonna
have to pay your student loans here's
how it works now but we'll help you with
that that's the point that's been the
point from the start yes we're not going
to pay them for you we're not going to
forgive them but we're actually going to
do what we've done for millions of
people and show you exactly how to get
out of the student loan debt it's
starting in October you need to get your
freaking act together that's right this
train is coming get off the track
hello okay get out of the truck let it
hit the truck but don't stay in the
truck whatever that get away from the
train really the good news is for Mo
almost all you I'm gonna help you find
not only the money you need to make that
payment but more yep it's called a
budget call the budget and we do it with
every dollar and Jade and Sam did it
they paid 465 000 in debt 200 plus of
that was student loan debt so she
actually did it you can't argue with
somebody who did it that's how it works
right and I used every dollar when it
the year that it came out Dave yeah and
it was clunkier it was clunky
it's robust and sophisticated yes now it
has all of the the tools and the
Trinkets and the things that I wished I
had back then now you get to use them
and the good news is I am doing a
webinar Dave yep you are this is an hour
and a half of your time on your lunch
break it's free
so it's free you bring your Lean Cuisine
you bring your sub sandwich and you sit
and I will help you figure out where
that margin is in your budget what
you've been missing why it didn't work
before and I will help you get it
working now so not only will we find
your student loan payment Because by the
way most people find about 332 dollars
in the first time they do about the
first time yes by the time they do a
budget for several months they find more
than that yeah because you get Sleek you
start their expenses by nine percent on
average you know what the inflation rate
was last year yeah nine percent there
you go ding ding and just found it we
found nine percent lost in your budget
yes and it's free
it's free did we mention that it's free
that's that's an important part there's
no you know I'll tell you something we
didn't mention is we mentioned this
yesterday and the stinking thing's
almost full yes it is so it does fill up
because the technology only allows us to
put so many people in the webinar yes so
if you want to be in the webinar I go to
everydollar.com budgeting that's right
science and sign up it's going to be
August 9th which would be like a week
from today yeah I think it's a Wednesday
yep yep week from week no yesterday's
Wednesday today's Thursday I'm so lost
yes me too well and I don't know when
you're listening to it on podcast anyway
ignore all of that but anyway yeah so
it's about a week not less than a week
away and it's completely free
everydollar.com budgeting Jade a limited
number of seats and they are not gone
but they're almost gone and it's free
and I'll be teaching you but you'll be
able to ask questions I'll be able to
hear from you this is a conversation
it's not just me yakking although I can
I can yeah you could fill it up but you
don't need to that's not what we're
doing yeah and the and by the way the
one of the topics is going to be how to
deal with an irregular on unpredictable
income so you're on commission you're
self-employed your hours are irregular I
can't do a budget yes you can we can
show you how we actually have a tool
inside of every dollar called paycheck
planning that allows you to do it so
good and you've got the financial
roadmap in there that shows you how to
walk right up the baby steps while
you're doing your every dollar budget I
mean this thing is good yeah and it's by
the way did we mention the ridiculous
price it's free 3.99 that's what I'm
talking about free 90.
that's funny all right Julie's in
Pennsylvania hi Julie welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi Dave and Jade how are you better than
we deserve what's up
uh my husband and I are currently
working through the baby steps in
talking about it we have
five on saving for your children's
college fund is there a recommendation
that you would have maybe of another way
to save for them that wouldn't be
specifically earmarked for college in
case they decide for some reason not to
go to college
no I would first save in the 529 for
college I wouldn't if you're as they age
as the kids grow up if you're feeling
more and more that they're going to go
where they do know after after high
school education which by the way is
highly unrecommended you don't have to
go to college to use the 529 you can go
to trade school
okay and that money converts from you
can go to code school and use it to
become a programmer okay it doesn't have
to be a four-year institution and
leaving high school and going to college
is not for everyone and certainly going
to college and studying you know German
polka history is stupid don't do that
right but but going so everybody
shouldn't go to college you know carte
blanche no matter what but everyone
should continue to gather knowledge
right everyone if you don't continue to
gather knowledge you're going to end up
broke your whole life so you need to be
a lifetime learner we do teach our
children knowledge is a currency that
will cause your life to win not degrees
and not uh snotty famous institutions it
doesn't matter where you go or that you
got a sheepskin what matters is do you
know something that you didn't know
yesterday so the number of books I have
read since I graduated from college 40
years ago is astronomical you know so
that's where I want you I want I want
them in that mode but all that to say
they can get certifications they can get
trade trade schools they can do all
kinds of things so I'm going to start
saving now if you get a hundred thousand
bucks in a kid's name and this kid is
going to be a welder uh you know you you
probably need to stop saying at that
point but right now you've got nothing
how many kids do you have right I have
two yeah the other thing is is the
siblings can use it yeah siblings can
use it some of the 529s even adults you
know the loss of spouses can use them
yeah and not spouses I'm sorry parents
parents you can use them their kids can
use yep
it's it's not it's not TR and even if
you did take it out you're just going to
pay a penalty on the growth that's right
that's all
and they can't convert to their
retirement down the line right yep it
can become a Roth IRA it takes forever
yeah it does but the point is there's
nothing's lost nothing's wasted good
option yeah yeah and and you know and
here let me tell you it's a good it's a
really good question you're asking okay
because a it gives us the ability to
clarify here's the other thing that
happened with my kids we didn't have
529s when the Ramsey kids were growing
up okay there's no such thing then so we
were just saving in a mutual fund in
their name that's called a unified gift
to minors act okay yeah and uh we just
say and you could do that if you want uh
because the money's at least going to be
taxed at their rate which is zero until
they get up to ten thousand dollars in
gain so it's it's largely zero but
anyway having that fund even if our kids
didn't go to college gave us the
opportunity to continually as parents
talk about hey here's your college fund
hey here's your college fund hey this is
your college fund hey we're putting
money in your college fund hey come over
here I want to show you how to calculate
how much is in your college fund share
price times number of shares and this is
how much is in your college fund and
what was I doing there yes I was
brainwashing them to go to college okay
that's true but but in addition to that
or instead of that if you wanted to say
this is your education fund that's good
Dave because education matters what
we're doing is we're we're part of the
rhythm of the Ramsey kitchen table was
ever so often you would hear from your
parents that learning matters
because we're saving for it we're
investing in your future because
learning matters because knowledge
matters and you do want that that's
another benefit of having the 529 just
keep talking about it but yeah
I I don't oversave if you think you've
got a kid but if you've got two doctors
or two lawyers you really can't save
enough so um but if you got if you got
you know a welder and a coder you you
can stop at some point because you're
not going to need as much to as you need
to go through med school they may make
more but they're not going to spend as
much to get the degree man that's a good
conversation it is and uh you know we've
had so much discussion with Ken Coleman
Mike Rowe about the trades trades are uh
they're on the comeback thank goodness
yeah uh yes that's what makes it good
one of the things made America great
yeah we know how to build stuff you know
that's right and uh we want to think
about think positively about people that
build stuff and they don't all have to
come from somewhere else it can just be
from across the street that's right
there's great pride in being a Craftsman
or there should be this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsay we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions on the debt free
stage Mark and Barbara are with us hey
guys how are you hey Dave hi we're doing
well good good where do you guys live uh
we live in Denver North Carolina oh fun
what's that Charlotte Charlotte
okay cool welcome to Nashville good to
have you guys thank you all the way over
here to do a debt free scream how much
did you pay off uh we paid off 215 600
woohoo yeah I like it and how long did
this take uh three and a half years good
for you and your range of income during
that time 120 to two and a quarter way
to go what do you all do for a living
I'm a sixth grade teacher good and I I
sell food for a living very good you
sell fruit for a living that's right A
lot of it yeah
that's a lot of apples
I like it I like it so what kind of debt
was the 216 000. we made out of our
house foreign
looking at weird people how old are you
two weirdos I'm 37. I'm 34. and you're
paid for house yep wow when you were 22
people told you that wasn't possible oh
sure yeah even now even now they tell
you it's not possible and you've already
done it and it's true yeah it's possible
I'm standing in it shut up yeah but yeah
it's it's just it's so weird isn't it
that's why we call people weirdoses
because it's the best kind of weirdo to
be because people a can't believe it can
happen and uh B they don't believe it
happens as much as it does happen lots
of people pay off their houses but
nobody talks about it much way to go you
got it thank you wow so what in the
world happened to you three and a half
years ago that Lit you up like this well
I mean it started like 12 years ago when
Barbara and I got engaged we got a gift
for Financial Peace University that we
took at that time so we've been trying
to live it ever since
um about four years ago I got a new job
and then we just did we just dream all
the time and plan and goal and so we
looked down like three and a half years
ago and said we can get this done in
maybe like five or six years maybe seven
before the kids get to high school and
then I don't know you just start getting
after it and you knock it out pretty
quick and it's it was just awesome I
love it way to go y'all that's so fun
I mean you're not even 40. what's this
house worth uh five 525 5 30 something
let's go and how much in your retirement
accounts about 300 way to go so you're
bumping up all Millions pretty close
yeah very close it's gonna be baby steps
millionaires in a minute yeah
and you're not even 40. you're not even
35. I mean come on wow that's amazing
that is how's it feel unbelievable it
feels really good have you had that
first month where there's no payment yet
yeah July was our first month oh tell me
about I like walk me through it walk me
through it well we did get the tax bill
that month too for the house but it was
the best bill that I've ever paid so I
was happy to pay that bill really oh man
but what big thing are you gonna do to
celebrate you got to do something cool
um we've been putting off certain kinds
of travel and vacations that we've
wanted to do and
um the good kind yeah right exciting
ones that you know some of them some
don't know about so yeah uh oh sorry we
can't say it in front of it yeah I can't
say in front of some of our audience
right so which happens to be sitting
over here to the left okay that's right
I know what you're talking about we
might well we all do now yeah that's
good okay also the ones that don't
involve them too yes
about them where are you going uh we'd
probably like to go down to like Key
West or somewhere around there yeah
that's a nice trip a little couple
things that's a good fair I love it not
a payment in the world yes not even 40.
years old debt no debt on the house what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is
um I mean I think one of the major
things is work I mean we're married so
we work as a team we work as one and you
know whether she's pulling me up which
is most of the time where I try to help
her out too it's it's getting after it
so
uh just you know remembering your why
and continuing to you know do God's work
with the money that you've been given
so I can is it I can do all things
through Christchurch
yeah okay that's a good that's a great
scripture obviously well done you guys
well done well done well done so um man
yeah I I mean when you were growing up
people talked about Millionaires and now
you're getting ready to be one yeah I
mean uh you know I took a new job that
kind of put us back a little bit but we
were still okay as far as income goes
but
um Barbara at the time was staying at
home with with our youngest uh and she
started opening her own business she got
after it I mean one of the big reasons
she kind of pushed us towards that
Finish Line really really fast was her
just doing stuff in her part time to buy
and sell and learn and I mean it was
very impactful and very inspirational
that she could take on something like
that to continue to help the household
and what were you selling anything that
would make me money yeah so you just
buying like garage sale stuff flipping
on eBay and yeah or Facebook Marketplace
or whatever yeah okay good for you well
done sounds like you did good with it
wow very good good good good man so you
get a hold of Dave's Book 12 years ago
because I'm I'm thinking about your
journey it sounds like you kind of
avoided debt in general for the past 12
years right even before you got intense
four years ago to pay off this house
yeah pretty close I mean we had probably
like most people do might have a credit
card because it seems like a good idea
for credit or we have a car payment but
we're going to pay it off early yeah
right right you know some of the things
that were probably pretty normal
um but you know we kind of had a wake-up
call to yeah kick it into high gear
that's right yeah very cool knock it out
this is just so and so I don't
understand how anybody can listen to
this and not be inspired and not believe
it can be done how many people do you
know in their 30s I have a paid for
house I mean we know lots of them Dave
because they come through here every day
but if you're listening this is I mean
this is what you can do you guys have
made it clear that this is what's
possible in life very very cool hey
bring the kiddos up let's introduce them
their names into ages
this is Stella with her beautiful blue
glasses on she's uh eight and then this
is Gabby she's four all right cute cute
and they got the t-shirts to match
that's right well done good stuff hey
we've got the live and give box for you
that's the baby steps millionaires book
you should read it because you're almost
there and Total Money Makeover book
that's one to give away and get somebody
else's Journey started and Financial
Peace University as well you can give it
or you can live it whatever you want to
do that's what the box is for thanks for
making the trip over thank you very much
you guys are inspiring Your Heroes
appreciate it Well Done Your Heroes to
those two you changed your family tree
man their lives will never be the same
they have no idea how important this day
is or the Milestone that the state
represents is and and what their mom and
dad sacrifices meant so well done you
guys very very very well done Mark and
Barbara Stella and Gabby Charlotte North
Carolina they paid off 216 000 in debt
that's house and everything almost baby
steps millionaires already ready man did
this in three and a half years making
120 to two and a quarter count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
[Music]
this is how it's done
there you go
wow I don't think we can say it or show
it or illustrate it or tie it together
any more clearly or often enough to tell
people the fastest way to build wealth
is to get out of debt that's right I
mean here they sit with a paid four half
million dollar house three hundred
thousand dollars in savings so they're
at 800k net worth and they're bumping up
on millionaire status they're going to
be a mult they're going to be
multi-millionaires yeah easily
um unless they just really screw this up
I mean they're really on track to be
probably have a 10 million dollar net
worth by the time they get in their 60s
that's the thing and all they did was
get their income back instead of giving
it to somebody else that's right we sit
and talk about this daily on the radio
and it's not just this idea it's not
just a theory we get to watch people do
it every day millions of people get a
hold of this information they change
their lives they pay off their debt they
pay off their homes and they become
millionaires yeah and so when we get the
haterade out there that says oh Dave
Ramsey stuff Ramsey stuff is just for
poor people it's just it's good first
steps but he doesn't really know
anything about wealth building you know
it doesn't hurt our feelings because we
know you're stupid right right when you
say that okay we understand but what it
does piss us off is you might somebody
might believe you're stupid butt stuff
true that when we created more
millionaires probably than any other
organization and currently operating in
America right now by doing that right
thing okay that's the fact it pisses me
off when somebody said when somebody
tries to put us in a bucket or in the
corner of not Building Wealth because
we've shown more people how to build
wealth than anybody anybody and not
because it hurts our feelings it doesn't
hurt us it doesn't change my net worth
when you do that but you convince
somebody else with your stupid but hope
stealing that they can't do it and we
sit here and show people every freaking
day that you can do it hope deferred
makes the heart sick but when desire
comes it is the tree of life this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Anisha is with us in Charlotte North
Carolina hi Anisha how are you
I'm great Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up so I'm calling about
the student loan debt relief and
everything that's transpiring the end of
September uh beginning of October I have
um some student loans that I have yet to
pay off it's only it's my last one and
I'm currently unemployed and I have the
money in my savings account and I want
to go forth with paying it off however I
am hesitant because I experienced a
situation before where I was inquired
some fees and taxes later on after
paying the debt off years ago and I just
want to make sure with what they have
and stated now with no interest if there
is no type of fees that will occur later
on or no type of taxes that will later
on occur for anyone
what are you pulling the money out of
that's what I'm asking
I'm going to be pulling it out of my
savings
not a not a retirement account
no sir the student loan the the
government's not going to assess you a
fee for paying off a federal student
loan early okay okay and I asked because
I guess before when I did it I pulled it
for my 401k yeah that was a problem
okay that's why that's why you yeah
that's why you had a tax deal and you
had some fees now my bigger question is
right now you don't have an income
coming in right
correct and how much were you pulling
out of your savings and what will it
leave
um I'll be pulling out twelve thousand
and what will it be
it will for that account at least 30.
okay and what did what did you used to
do for a living
um I was actually in marketing
unfortunately
um when I was seven months pregnant they
let me go
um say that they were getting rid of my
position at the beginning of the year
and um so I it's my husband's income
that we are working on what does he what
does he make
the 80 000 what did you used to make
60 okay and you've had the baby now
yes sir congratulations that's great
thank you and you didn't have the weight
of working for a toxic horrible company
while you were having a baby that's a
wonderful blessing
you're exactly right thank you is this
your only debt
this uh I have a car alone and that's
the last bit of my day income right now
um sorry one more question I'm digging a
little bit both of you combined is this
your only debt
yes okay great so your finances are
combined yes sir okay you keep using you
should keep saying me but I didn't I
want to make sure he's not I'm sorry
he's not he's not sitting on 300 000
over here in a different account or more
savings because my next question you
said that that would leave 30k in
savings so I'm wondering about the car
how much do you owe on your car
yeah I owe 9 000. girl let's pay them
both off
that's what my husband said
he's right next yeah are you are you
going back to work after the baby gets a
little bit older yes I want to go after
he's turned at least give them to a
first and first year with me
um and then go back to work but uh so
can you guys make it a year a year more
because you got about a year left
can you make it a year on his income
with no payments
I think so and that's why you got no car
payment I know and we're currently
renting in our apartment that's okay um
we do we do want to buy yeah and we're
fine with it we do want to eventually
buy a house next year and so not just
where my brain is it's like gosh 12 000
or should I go ahead and wipe all this
clear we completely be debt-free and
then the Lord is just going to continue
to provide for us excuse me as he has
before and open up doors no man can
close you know in his word he says we
are he wants us to be lenders and not
borrowers you know and I just keep that
in my mind and I'm like Lord I trust you
you know you've done it before you'll do
it again and so well I also trust him to
grow clearance I I agree with every
single thing you just said and on top of
that I trust him that the corn will grow
after I plant it
yes turns out the corn doesn't grow by
itself I gotta plan it so you you're
gonna do your part by clearing the debt
living on a budget the mind of man plans
his ways but the Lord directs his steps
so we're gonna have a plan don't build a
tower without first counting the cost
unless you get halfway up and are able
to finish so we're gonna have a budget
you and your husband are gonna live
you're going to do your part to make
these scriptures the truth of these
scriptures come alive in your life does
that make sense
yes sir you're incredible I think you're
going to be awesome you you're going to
get to spend time with this baby we're
going to be on a detailed plan and the
plan is going to include when you go
back to work a bunch of your income if
not all of it's going to be able to pile
up to base save up for a house yes sir
do you have incredible but I believe
you're there do you have every dollar
Anisha
I used to have it and it was when I had
it at the time it wasn't operating well
with my bank account now it will I just
stopped it okay I want you to I don't
know who's your bank
um it was I have Bank well I got a
couple it's
it's America
Wells Fargo
aside from every dollar I would just
have a suggestion don't do business with
either one of those they're both
horrible but every dollar will
definitely connect to Bank of America
and Wells Fargo no question about it
hold on and go to everydollar.com Jade
and get a year 15 off on me oh there you
go yeah everydollar.com Jade promo code
15 off and you'll get it for a year
super cheap I need to get a slash Dave I
don't have a slush day you got to know
people Dave you got to know the right
you gotta have the connection to get a
slash Dave that's right Dave could be
like a horror that could that sounds a
little negative that sounds
the psycho
hey uh Anisha you're incredible yeah go
do this plan and follow all the way
through okay don't don't go pay off
these two things and be irresponsible
and call me back later and say ah we
hadn't even working so I ran a bunch of
debt no you're gonna get on every dollar
Jay just gave you the slash Jade and so
uh you got the 15 off get on there you
and your husband sit down let's lay out
a plan so that this whole thing turns
into a blessing because here's what's
going to end up happening and you can't
see it yet but I've seen it before so
I'll go ahead and predict it okay when
you go back to work
you are wiser than when you took that
last job
and you have more knowledge about
marketing than when you took that last
job when you go back to work you're
going to make more money than you were
making when those idiots fired you
mm-hmm
and it's going to be a better company
because you are going to choose a place
that pays you more and that is worthy to
have you there and you are going to walk
and move in a different type of
confidence because you don't have this
dead around your neck and that
confidence is going to cause you to
attract better opportunities you
interview better when you're not
desperate that's a fact desperate sales
people smell bad just telling you when
you're trying to sell yourself in an
interview yeah you can smell it it's
ugly when you're desperate it's a lot of
God I just told you it's hard for me to
clean the dishes out of anything I mean
it's just it's probably done interview
well I'm just saying yeah yeah but uh
hey you're incredible I I really can see
incredible stuff and it all comes off
with a simple question I didn't want
fees for my student loan that's right
yeah isn't that funny isn't that weird
but we got all the way down into our
life we did yeah so that's the way that
works around here because see money's
not people who just answer money
questions they miss the point because
it's all about your life
all about you I mean she got a brand new
baby she's not sleeping much right now
nope
and trying to figure out how to do all
this stuff but she's about to pay off
her student loans and her car and still
have money saved and her husband's gonna
smile that's right and say it was my
idea for once I was right
just call Ramsey they'll tell you I was
right that's right it doesn't happen
often but when it does occasionally you
gotta play the Robert's right card yeah
yeah you don't you don't play them often
but you just occasionally Just Gotta
Throw It Down on the table there yeah
so I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have to
work on my slash Dave yeah slash Dave
there's I know some people in this
building Dave and I think they can hook
you up yeah okay
well my name's on the front part of the
slash it is that's the Ramsay Solutions
part so maybe I just maybe they just
thought I didn't need a back shot
possible you never know but
oh
ho ho ho
now we're getting to it oh boy so does
that mean anybody goes to backslash
Slade that Jade they could get 15 that's
right if anybody types it in Dave we are
beautiful
over the dead gum Airwaves that's right
it's a secret code so this is what
happens when somebody gives you a slash
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
filled wealth
do work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade warshaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five Courtney starts this
hour in San Diego hi Courtney welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi thank you so much Dave it's a
pleasure to speak to you you too what's
up
I have a question regarding my husband's
car I am wondering if it would be
reasonable for me to beg plead ask him
to sell the car to get us
um closer to our financial goals and get
us further out of debt
no
you shouldn't be begging and pleading
your husband to get your financial goals
in order the two of you should be
talking about getting your financial
goals in order and then he looks around
and says oh one of the things I need to
do to do that is sell my car yeah
oh I didn't expect you to say that all
right
I can do that I can do that yeah I think
I think he the two of you need to be so
sharing of these goals that he looks
around says what's best for the family
is this so I mean tell me about the car
what's the situation with it
um
he per 300 000 McLaren knowing that he
was going to lose his job and he did
lose his job in February of 2022. and
he's been trying to build a business a
software company he spent a hundred
thousand dollars of our savings on the
software company and it's
um going a lot slower than he
anticipated and we're living on my
income in Southern California which is
what they're called
um I am a property manager and all of my
properties that I've purchased are free
and clear of debt and um I make
um 225
000 in rent but a huge portion goes to
property insurance
um property taxes so what do you take
home
Etc less than 100 000 and what was he
making before
three hundred thousand doing what a
software engineer he was a CFO of a
Healthcare Company okay
okay
um So Courtney what your the the car
is not the problem the car is the
symptom of him doing extreme behaviors
man
yeah I agree what's scaring is
terrifying you
it's terrifying me listening to it
yeah it's really frightening yeah
I've prayed a lot about it but I I think
he needs to hear you say loud and clear
that he's scaring you to death you're
terrifying me this feels so
irresponsible
the car the the in combination with the
software company the fact that you would
go do that right before it has nothing
to do with the car it's got through the
fact that you would go do that right
before you know you're losing your job
and right before you before you do a
startup how much savings do you have now
I know you said he pulled out a hundred
thousand
and now it's less than a hundred
thousand and it's dwindling very very
rapidly so you don't have any net worth
left you're using that to float your
life right now
exactly is the McLaren paid for
oh we have a hundred and fifty thousand
dollar car loan so I was hoping that we
could at least get the car paid off so
that we wouldn't have that additional
payment yeah every month so at eight
percent yeah so what I what I'm
suggesting is is that you pan back and
that he panned back and look at your
lives
and you may need to sit down you do need
to sit down with a good marriage
counselor with a good pastor or somebody
to guide you that he will trust and and
talk to because
um if you pan back
what what I would tell him if he was my
buddy and he asked if he asked me I
would tell him is your extreme high risk
behavior is terrifying your family
you're traumatizing your wife
is completely out of line
and the you know it's almost like you're
living a mid-life crisis and dragging
your family along with you
and so you you need to get a job and
sell your car not because you need to
get a job and sell your car but because
you need to do some actions that are not
extreme high risk bizarre behavior to
tell your wife you haven't lost your dad
gum mind
well it almost sounds like that that
kind of is what happened it's like this
denial of be before he was having this
300 000 income that would be 45
he's 52. okay close enough yeah like
I've done this before okay it's like
he's not accepting that that's not the
reality in the moment so here's what I'm
saying there's something about the CFO
thing going away
and something about what's going on
inside of him that's causing extreme
behaviors
are this leading him to go to engage in
extreme behaviors these are desperate
lurches
and that's what needs to be fixed the
McLaren is just a symptom of that
does that make any sense it does
absolutely and so if I don't I don't
really I don't think you're gonna gain
much ground that you want to gain by
going in and saying Dave Ramsey said so
the McLaren I mean he's probably just
look at you and go who the crap is Dave
Ramsey I'm not selling my car and so um
you know and so he doesn't really care
what I think but but what I would tell
you is if I were in your shoes and I
think you you I think you're verifying
you're terrified you're traumatized by
his behaviors I I think we if I were you
I would coach you to I would to address
that and then the McLaren getting rid of
that is a If he if he calms down this
these desperate lurches uh anyone with
with a little sense of peace and dignity
and Destiny that's not lurching and you
know reaching is going to immediately
look up and go we can't afford 150 000
car payment I mean it's just
if you told me you had a 20 million
dollar net worth that may be okay but
yeah are you confident in this are you
confident in his business venture like
in your head are you going he's he's the
type of guy that makes money he's gonna
do it or are you like no this is not it
well we've been down this road before
and so I'm cautiously optimistic if
that's uh too evasive I I really I can't
even I I'm cautiously optimistic but
he's been trying to sell this software
since February and yeah no it hasn't
moved and so our he does need additional
income at this moment and that is what
he's been resistant to and
um even on his birthday which was just a
few days ago he told me he's absolutely
not selling the car that is not because
his daughter asked no
um our 13 year old said dad I you
promised you would sell the car why are
you gonna sell the car and he said no
never never selling the car
um so I think there's something going on
it's not it was an identity breakdown um
he's gotten his identity into I'm a
player
and the car and the joint and the car in
the uh the startup represent I'm a
player and I can't turn my back on
either one of them because then I
wouldn't be a player and I'm a player
that wins that's what he thinks and he's
afraid he's not he's afraid he's opposer
and so yeah you guys need some
counseling hun I'm sorry I'm sorry
you're going through this it is
terrorizing you have a right to be uh
very afraid
um the the the conditions are not good
but the car is a symptom not a problem
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
thank you
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host thank you for joining us America
we are glad you're here all month long
we're giving away cash you could win one
of the 500 weekly prizes or the grand
prize of three thousand dollars no
purchase necessary all you gotta do to
enter is go to ramseysolutions.com
giveaway you can interrupt it once a day
if you enter more than that the computer
kicks you out so you did no good try it
try it try it doesn't work uh you can
also get our best-selling books like The
Total Money Makeover from paycheck to
purpose and own your pass change your
future from Dr John deloney as low as 12
his brand new book coming
October 3rd is called building a
non-anxious life you'll learn the six
daily choices to break free from a life
spinning out of control you can
pre-order that book now for twenty
dollars if you do you get seventy five
dollars in free bonus items and his
questions for humans cards are on sale
for only twelve dollars at Ramsay
solutions.com that is some life-changing
stuff free money good deals good deals
lots of helpful information that's what
we're about around here
ramseysolutions.com slash store
even the store has a slash it does
you're
you're left out in the cold Dave yet
again
Stacy's in Louisiana hi Stacy welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi thank you sure what's up
I have a whole life policy that has been
paid off it's a 15
000 policy that my dad took out for me
and now the benefit amount is 47 399.
so my question is
um and I called them I can keep the
death benefit at 15 000 and they're
telling me I can move a portion of it to
an IRA Roth
and make 4.5 percent on it
and I didn't know if I should just leave
it in there and leave it as a death
benefit or just leave the death benefit
at fifteen thousand and then use that
other What's the forty seven thousand
that is the death benefit paid out now
the cash value yeah no the cash value is
000. so if you close the policy if you
close the policy up you get twenty five
thousand dollars
correct okay well let me kind of reset
the table for you before I tell you what
to do okay
because you're using the phrasing that
the whole life agents teach you okay
that's what I'm calling you yeah so
as long as you're alive there is a
probability of your death agreed
agreed as long as there is a probability
of your death there is a cost
to life insurance for them to cover you
it costs them something because each
year there's a chance you will die and
and you can break that down by year if
you're an insurance company that's what
you would do it's called an Actuarial
Table okay and so for for the re fact
that as long as you're alive there they
cost them there is never a time that you
have paid off a policy what has happened
is you have prepaid a policy they
charged you such high premiums and your
dad such high premiums in the early days
that they never aren't going to charge
you again okay that's thing number one
okay how old are you
I am 56. now I'll tell you this Dave I
know we paid like 69 a month yep forever
50 years so it for no just for 20 years
it's paid off yeah he paid for 69 a
month you could have had a million and a
half dollars in Insurance well exactly
but this was 20 years ago so that's what
no it was the same cause the same cost
back then so but the point is is that
you overpaid and prepaid and so they
finally quit charging you because they
got enough of your money what number one
thing number two thing a fifteen
thousand dollar policy the interest on
twenty five thousand dollars would buy a
fifteen thousand dollar policy
right okay I mean if you took the 25 000
out and put it in a savings account the
interest would buy you a fifteen
thousand dollar policy so you're paying
for your policy in lost interest because
this thing's not earning anything that's
the other problem with it the third
thing is if you die uh you said the
death benefit is now 47 so this must be
a mutual company they've been doing
add-ons
um it's Knights of Columbus yeah they've
been in an add-ons okay yeah so you've
been buying more insurance as you went
along uh and so you've got a higher
death benefit than fifteen thousand now
you have a death benefit of 47 000
because you've been using some of your
dividends to buy additional Insurance
paid up additions are called okay and uh
that that's what's happened and so all
of this to say
um sadly this whole Endeavor has not
been a good move keeping it is not going
to be a good move if it were me I would
just cash it out and take the 25 000 and
invest it
period so
they were kind of telling me I couldn't
invest it through them no you can't
because I already you can okay you
cannot roll over a whole life cash value
of 25 000 into an IRA you can put eight
thousand dollars into an IRA if you have
an earned income of that but whole life
life insurance is not in a retirement
program it cannot be rolled to an IRA
that is not true okay now they can't
they could invest they could take some
of your money up to eight thousand
dollars and invest it into an IRA and
paying you four and a half percent will
be screwing you again
because a good mutual fund should pay 10
to 12 percent in a good Roth IRA which
is where you need to be with this 25
000. so what they're okay you know their
whole life agents it's what they do uh
they believe in it or they don't believe
in it and they know they're ripping
people off but either way they're
ripping people off and so what you need
to do is go to a good smartvester Pro
and cancel this policy and take the 25
000 and put it in good mutual funds uh
you can put 8 000 in if you're married
you can put 16 000 in because your
spouse and then the next year you could
put another ten thousand in so over two
calendar years you can get it moved into
a Roth IRA but you can do that with or
without doing this
you can put that much money into a Roth
IRA anyways that's all this is
my my head is spinning on this a little
bit because I just did a little bit of
just my jade math I'm like she said
she's paid 69 for 20 years for 20 years
to get a 15 000 death benefit if you
just that that math on that it's 16 560
so she paid more money to get less of a
death benefit
yeah and uh we'll just add let's just go
ahead because we can't you know we just
got to explain to folks so there's two
types of mutual funds two types of uh
insurance companies there's mutual and
standard standard is the stock is a
stockholders on the company and the
profits go the stockholders Mutual
is the State Farm Knights of Columbus
Northwestern Mutual yeah anything so
it's a Mutual of Omaha Mutual is the
policyholders own the company now and
then they pay you dividends now let me
let's walk us through okay if a company
makes a profit
it charged the customer more than the
cost of the item and so if if you're the
owner of the company and the customer of
the company and they give you some of
the profit back it's because they
charged you too much to start with so
you just it's like a tax return it's not
a co-op and so the the the treasury
Department has ruled that life insurance
uh Dividends are not true dividends
there's your money to begin with because
it's just a circular thing you gave them
too much and they gave you some of it
back tax return and so yeah it's like a
tax return in that regard I see what
you're saying but the the treasury
Department has ruled it's not an income
it's not taxable life insurance
Dividends are not our State Farm if you
got a car and they send you a dividend
it's not taxable it's because it's It's
the Return of a deliberate overcharge is
what the treasury Department says which
is exactly what it is yeah so in in her
case what they did was they took that
money instead of giving it back to her
and bought more more life insurance for
her yes and that's called paid up
additions and that's why she had a forty
seven thousand dollar death benefit
instead of a fifteen thousand dollar
death benefit I kind of feel like that
should be illegal it's Shady
stinking thing is Shady whole life life
insurance is the worst Mutual whole life
life insurance is the worst of the worst
and guess what
it's the payday lender of the middle
class clearly
you know you think payday lenders
screwing the poor people they are whole
life life insurance payday lender of the
middle class right there that's why
their buildings are so tall this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today I'm Dave
Ramsey this is the Ramsey Show
hey if you want to help us out we could
use your help because you're our entire
marketing budget you guys thank you we
don't have 300 million to spend on uh
naming a stadium after us or buying a
bunch of ads like so if I uh but no
instead we're just here helping you so
if you want to help us out we could use
the help and the way you could help us
is subscribe to the show follow the show
leave a five-star review of the show
share the show click the share button
let your friends know to listen tell
people about how and where you're
listening whether it's talk radio or TBN
or podcast or YouTube or whatever it is
and we know a bunch of you are doing
that because it's working
all of our numbers are up up up up up up
up thank you like this week uh we're
number 12. on Apple podcasts that's of
all Apple podcasts in the world there's
four million of them we're number 12.
because of you guys thank you that's
important because when you pull up a
podcast listen to there's six in a row
and that means by not being number 12
we're like the last one right there so
you can we're like the first thing you
see you can see it with the with the you
know all the rest of them are like all
crime that's right all dead people and
cereal and all that stuff it's funny no
there's I mean there's this American
life there's some other uh news type
things on there but uh we're certainly
the only show of this type that's in
that top 12 but thank you guys thank you
thank you thank you thank you very very
much we appreciate you Stephanie is in
Atlanta hi Stephanie welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi Steve how are you great how can we
help
um actually I have a question I am uh
I'm really excited because I am debt
free as of this morning
[Applause]
that's great
um it was uh a little over 223 000 wow
and I started yeah it was a lot and I
started um just shy of four years ago
and I actually took some of your advice
and uh went to my I made a really high
salary actually um 180 000 but I was one
of those broke High salary people
um I had a fancy house and my daughter
went to a fancy school and I had a fancy
car and I went on fancy vacations
and uh it was kind of a it was a fun but
you know go nowhere kind of Road and uh
I went to my employer and asked them if
I could do sales to make extra income
because I'm an operations manager I
asked them if I could do sales on the
side and they said yes and if I took um
I paid off about a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars that way wow and then
um yeah and it took a couple years but
but it was kind of awesome and then uh I
my company closed the company closed
this this January of this year and I got
a similar job but it pays uh only a
hundred and so that for me was a huge I
mean an enormous pay cut yeah and
um I thought oh no I still had student
loans I 55 000 of student loans I still
had one big credit card and um and a car
and I wasn't there yet so I did
something that was very difficult I sold
my house wow I yeah I sold my house and
then I moved to uh where my family's
from because where I lived with St
Petersburg Florida very high cost of
living there and I moved back up to my
family's firm which is Northwest of
Atlanta kind of that Kennesaw Marietta
area and I am the question I have is a
tip that I wanted to say yay for me
because I'm very excited but I've been
I'm on every dollar you know I'm on
Ramsey plus and I did my budgets that
way and that was one of the ways that I
kept track of everything because there
were a lot of items to pay off obviously
and it's very exciting also when you're
in the online or in your account and you
can see everything you've paid off and
when I look at it now like I was looking
at it today waiting to get on the show
and I'm like wow I mean I did that I I
first of all I why did I get into all
that debt but I got rid of it you know
and it's a huge list so it's very
exciting
in the Ramsay plus but
um my question is so now I have uh 300
000 left over
from the Salem zoo and I want I put 50
000 in my emergency fund and so that I'm
probably that's probably over funded but
that leaves me with 250.
um and I'm kind of confused I'm 48. I'm
kind of confused about do I pay cash
that money because I'm staying with
family right now because I literally
moved three days ago
which is fine I mean it's it's a big
house it's fine so I um do I pay cash
for a house with that money or do I just
put a large down payment and invest the
rest of retirement because I only have
about I don't know 10 grand in my
retirement accounts I have I have
nothing to know right now and I only
have like 20 years left you know
so
is it just it's just you no kids no
you're not attached in any way
in that yes I have yes I am I have a
significant other and I have an
eight-year-old daughter you're outside
of Atlanta pretty far out
um I would start looking at homes that
suit your needs you don't have to buy a
big you know four bedroom home you're in
right not so much of a
um can you buy something for 250 that'll
do
fun
you know because that was baby step
three yeah you don't need 50 000 in
emergency you could have 30 000 probably
be fine and if you needed to beef this
up to 270 to buy something in cash
true true yeah
yeah so you can find some stuff up here
um that's I mean we don't need a big
house for the three of us so um you know
yeah and that range the two 275 295.
yeah and uh just just for clarity
significant others don't have their
names on Deeds
and you you know you're paying cash for
it
what you do besides that is yeah yeah so
you pay cash if I were in your shoes I
would pay cash
you would and and then there's there's
two things there's two things that'll
happen later one is you're going to be
able to because you don't have any uh
any payments of any kind anywhere uh
you're you're going to be able to pick
and choose the best possible career path
without pressure
oh I have another job now it just
doesn't pay as well I know that's the
point it doesn't pay as well though I
heard that part okay so I I I think
you've proven in the past that you're
worth more than you're currently being
paid you took a job because you needed a
job now you don't need a job as much and
so it's going to mean you're going to
adjust your career path uh in the next
36 months the second thing that's going
to happen is you're going to start
investing and building Your Nest Egg so
that you're a millionaire soon and you
would be fairly quickly at this process
because you are so intentional and
you're so focused and then the fourth
thing that's going to happen is you're
going to save up a bunch of money also
and end up oh probably five years from
now you'll move up in house and pay cash
for the move up
hey you said it's three of us version
three this is not forever a significant
other than our kid okay her kid or the
significant others kid that's what I was
trying to call architecture okay got you
got you okay we're basically married
we're just not legally we've been
together for like get legally married
what are y'all wearing
we didn't mean to not we did this kind
of I don't know okay so you'll go you'll
go this weekend it's kind of like kind
of like the money stuff yeah it's
intentional instead of accidental yeah
well congratulations on getting married
yeah and debt free and selling a house
and a move and a career you got quite a
life going in this is great yeah I pay
cash because it's not forever is my
point
okay okay you probably won't be there
more than five years
because I'm thinking if I'm 48 this year
I have you know I don't think you're
going to be there five years
okay and you're gonna earn more
and you're gonna move up later and
you're going to invest and invest and
invest invest because you're currently
worried about it which is good which
makes you now intentional about that
when you were worried about the debt you
got rid of it and now that Jade's got
you worried about getting married you'll
get married and so now whatever you
worry about you you attack it and get it
done so it's all good and that's a good
thing that's how life works and so
um she didn't know she was getting
married this weekend until we informed
her so that's exciting yeah it's good I
mean you know you can get a lot of
information on the Ramsey that's right
that you didn't ask for it's totally
free it's completely free this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
27 13 I remain confident of this I will
see the goodness of the Lord in the land
of the living
Max Lucado says God does some uncommon
things through common people in common
places
yeah we kind of proved that around here
every day
yeah we've had a lot of uncommon uh
impact and we're a bunch of common folk
are doing it I'm just saying open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five Jade wash all Ramsay
personality is my co-host Rachel is in
Dallas hi Rachel welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi
hi thank you so much for taking my call
today I my husband and I my husband and
I have been trying we've done day dish
for about 10 years and we've made every
mistake you've ever told anybody not to
do
um and if you saw us in person you would
probably flick us upside the head
um not you just your husband
no well maybe maybe just him
um so my problem is we are trying to be
we're trying to actually do the baby
steps um without actually doing the baby
step at this time my problem is is when
we line up our debt
um we have a huge bill to the IRS
um we owe currently about twenty five
thousand dollars
um and so it's it would be our biggest
debt next to the house and so I I think
I know the answer is that we don't put
that at the bottom of the list we would
attack that first that's right right
that's right yeah so um what do you owe
on your home
um 280
what's it worth
about 300 320.
uh
is your credit screwed up with all these
other problems you've had
no our credit is fantastic we have a
huge credit score Dave okay
um I would go to the bank and talk about
some kind of home equity loan I'm not
sure you got enough equity to do it but
if you can pull 25k off your house and
pay the IRS off I would
yeah
because I'd rather owe the bank than the
IRS the IRS has the highest fees the
highest interest and almost unlimited
power to screw with your life
yeah and they're doing it yeah I would
want them out of my life as fast and as
much as possible you don't want to deal
with the KGB if you can help it so if
you can borrow from anybody you're going
to have a better deal than they're
giving you
and get them out of your life that's
that's going to be and so as Dave Ramsey
telling you to borrow money no Dave
Ramsey's telling you to take one kind of
debt that you have and move it to
another kind of debt
so it's not that's not that's not new
borrowing we're just transferring we're
changing the shape of the debt uh to
make it better to make it more
manageable what's your household income
good and what uh
uh where'd the IRS debt come from
um a a stupid mistake with zeros on it
my husband told he left one job and
decided to have a little fun for a while
and pulled a whole bunch of money out of
his 401. so it's a one-time stupid thing
and you know not to do it again so it's
not going to reoccur oh that's
absolutely no I'll kill him first
um yeah and so where are we the taxes
are still due if he's dead so let's just
keep that in mind
at least I'll have a good life insurance
policy job though well until they
discover the murder part but yeah
Jefferson on that part
joking aside have both of you had enough
of this are you both on board yeah yeah
but I I I am definitely because what do
you describe with him as an unbelievably
irresponsible Act
yeah that's not an issue that's not a
sort of today Ramsey that's I just went
off the deep end of insanity for a few
minutes yeah and I can't solely blame
him because I had some fun in there too
but um yeah we lived like kings for a
year well this is the kind of fun that
leaves a hangover that lasts for years
it definitely does yeah
so um yeah yeah the thing is yeah I
would go borrow on my house as a part of
my complete life transformation
but not as a way to try to escape
responsibility for my stupid actions
yeah
so if you're gonna go play all the way
through and get all these debts paid off
yeah do that but if not what I'm telling
you is not really going to help you it's
just a small part of the overall thing
um
but my concern would be if I borrow from
the bank and this is going to sound
stupid I know because I know the answer
is the interest rates right now are much
lower than the IRS they're still going
to be better okay they're still going to
be better okay because you're also
getting compounded late fees
yeah the penalty the penalties are what
get you with the IRS and do they have
unlim they can disrupt your life they
can come just take your paycheck or put
a lien on your house or I mean their
power is no other creditor has anywhere
near the kind of power they have no bank
I mean Banks if they wanted to sue you
it would take them forever if they want
to foreclose it takes them forever the
IRS just slaps people around when at
will and they do a horrible job
communicating with you you gotta wait
for a letter in the mail if they decide
to send it you just you really don't
want to be at their Mercy it's not worth
it and so yeah I really don't care about
the interest because again it's the law
it's let's say that all of a sudden one
of your checks was gone
see that that's a bigger deal than
interest rate for you getting your life
straightened out
yes that's why I'm doing this so yeah I
want you to get control of the variables
that we can control
Dax is in Salt Lake hi Dax what's up
hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
great so I'm 25 uh my wife is 21 and she
for the most part we've been able to you
know stay out of debt and do okay as far
as that goes but she's looking to go
into dental school and uh that's
expensive as I'm sure you know
um and I'm just trying to figure out the
best way to uh just me and her how we
can if there's all alternatives to going
into to you know getting student loans
and if not what's the best way to
approach that
um this sounds like she decided this
this morning
the way you described it not exactly she
started going to school for uh software
engineering
um and she hated it
um and uh this has been something we've
been thinking about for a few months now
yeah
I wouldn't do it I think it's BS how
much did you spend on the software
engineering
um so at that point her mom was able to
help her with that so there's no student
debt yeah no student debt right now
here's the thing okay she is not
completely sold out bought in on this
she's 21 years old and this is a 500 000
decision
and there's not a chance I'm doing this
not a chance
and certainly not going to go into death
to do it because here's the deal let me
just tell you you go five hundred
thousand dollars in debt to be a dentist
400 000 in debt to be a dentist you're a
dentist
even if you don't like it Tuffy wuffy
you're a dentist because you have to
clean this freaking mess up you don't
get to change your mind and decide you
hate it later because you just dug the
biggest freaking hole you can't even see
out of please don't do this
right yeah you're not gonna do it that
you're not gonna do it you don't want to
tell your wife no dude I'm telling you
please I'm begging you do not do this
if she wants to be a dentist let me tell
you how to do it this will end the whole
conversation join the military they'll
pay for it
mic drop
she's not doing that no no
she doesn't want it that bad nope uh she
might change her mind and not like it
yeah nope nope nope nope nope nope
someone who just changed their mind
after working on a degree for three
years because they hate it and three
months later wants to go five hundred
thousand dollars in debt if she told me
she wanted to be a dentist for the rest
for her whole entire life and you just
ran into her and you're part you're
grafting into the story of being a
dentist that's a different conversation
I'm not going to tell you to go into
debt to do it then but in this case I'm
gonna beg you do not do this not to
mention if she had paid for the
education of the software degree or if
she had to carry the debt from it no way
she'd be making that choice absolutely
absolutely please don't do this
[Music]
but they're gonna do it yeah we'll do a
moment of silence for them right now
yeah that puts the shower the Ramsey
Show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
foreign
if you love the show and want a deeper
dive on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]